j'ai vu que marlène schiappa donc allez
allez a saisi l'ordre des gynécologues
après la ferme à une vague est après
laffaire delà de la vulve
kwassa kwassa kwassa leur entame on voit
la vidéo et vous allez nous dire
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai qu'on en a
débattu hier et c'est vrai que voilà on
croyait que l'histoire était close
l'affairé était close mais non pour
également parlé des 30 km en
effet les machines en fait au niveau de
mon vagin genre de la radiofréquence et
ses valeurs la maison thérapie sans aux
jo sans injection est en fait que ça
rajeunit le vagin genre c'est trop bien
normand j'ai de la chance c'est vraiment
beau à jeun georges pas les lèvres
pourquoi qui dépasse mais il faut
l'entretenir
du coup c'est trop bien genre la passe
comme si j'avais tout sans jour
[Rires]
donc vous avez saisi l'ordre des
gynécologues
l'ordre des gynécologues et
obstétriciens
avoir ce que je voudrais rappeler ce qui
est important c'est que ce qu'a dit
cette influence euse a des conséquences
et je pense que quand on est entendu et
regardé par des enfants et des
adolescents on a une responsabilité pour
autant je tiens à dire que rien ne
justifie l'acharnement dont l accord
toile et bravo tu viens de le dire c'est
bien le dire ensuite dans cette vidéo ce
qui est choquant c'est qu'un médecin et
que cette vidéo n'est fait dans le
cabinet d'un médecin marianne
d'anthologie mais on peut quand même
s'interroger sur le fait qu'un médecin
par type non seulement effectué ce type
d'opération mais surtout en fait la
promotion alors oui marlène schiappa
requis ministre chargé de la citoyenneté
a saisi bien cet ordre des médecins pour
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé parce que ça
pose quand même des questions on parle à
un moment donné cette personne parle
d'une d'avoir un vagin d une petite
fille de 12 ans c'est la sexualisation
des enfants sur j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes et notamment les
enfants mais à 12 ans si vous saviez à
quel point les enfants sont influencés
par ça à quel point ça peut avoir des
incidences dans leur vie donc oui je
pense que les médecins doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités
mais ceci dit je pense aussi qu'à un
combat de société derrière tout ça bah
c'est à dire que ce qu'on voit et
j'écoutais donc cette influence à skis
c'est quand même excusé faut le dire la
tuerie excusé vallée ça pose quand même
la question de l'éducation à la
sexualité à la vie affective aux
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
entre les filles et les garçons et on
voit bien quand on voit ça y est on le
sait aujourd'hui la plupart des enfants
aujourd'hui des adolescents ils font
partie leur éducation sur internet sur
les réseaux sociaux fait notamment par
ces personnes qui sans doute le fil
malgré elle je ne lui jette pas je lui
jette pas la pierre je me dis finalement
quelle est finalement le sens en moi
aussi d'une société dans lequel est bien
on enferme les femmes alors image à leur
sexualité ou alors on les pousse à
justement à voir ses standards de beauté
qui n'ont aucun sens et qu'ils seront
même qui vont les faire souffrir par la
suite mais elle a peut-être choisi ça à
la choisi son destin aussi un maximum de
monde et que son but aussi c'est
peut-être tout simplement d'être belle
juste urbain se sent belle comme ça
j'aurai agréé côté guillaume genton qui
est pas du tout d'accord ah mais pardon
mais la fosse d acquérir l as faux sur
toute la ligne marine chapa elle dénonce
je cite le fait de promouvoir des
pratiques chirurgicales alors déjà il ya
aucune promotion c'était pas un
placement de produit c'était gentil
story dans laquelle elle filme et sa vie
et ensuite pratiques chirurgicales non
il n'y a pas eu d'opération elle a
simplement fait une épilation qui s'est
mal passé elle sert il rappellera
qu'après un mois je pense qu'elle veut
faire que de la forme c'est à dire du
buzz en s'attaquant à une candidate qui
est très populaire sur les réseaux
sociaux au détriment du fond et sans
s'intéresser au fond la moindre des
choses serait de se renseigner sur
l'histoire de france maintenant les
opérations cet influent 16 parle de ça
sur les réseaux sociaux elle donne des
informations qu'on prend quoi qu'elle
est dans le cabinet d'un chirurgien d'un
médecin et qui cautionnent ce type de
pratique c'est ça le message que ça
envoie et ça c'est ça que le fait que
cette personne le fasse oui c'est sa
liberté elle fait ce qu'elle veut par
contre le message qu'elle fait passer là
il ya une responsable italienne
responsabilité pour moi pour le
maintenant elle a beau raconter ce
qu'elle veut c'est pas une femme
politique j'ai pas dit le contraire moi
j'ai pas dit qu'elle n'avait pas le
droit à la liberté d'expression mais je
pense qu'on est responsable aussi
moralement du message qu'on envoie à des
gamines de 12 ans à des enfants très
jeunes qui vont entendre ça et qu'ils
vont se dire ah mais en fait je suis pas
anormal a bien fait peut-être ils vont
me faire opérer c'est assez grave de
fréquents allers-retours à g déjà de
base bachy
les problèmes